here's what we're going to get beautiful
brown bear I can see some lovely curves
around very nice I want you to think
with me a simple simple question which
is what do you know about the derivative
of this ground like all we've got is the
picture we know that doesn't fit like
all of the laws of differentiation that
we already know because it's just a
different kind of functional together
right um it's not as though like if you
just think about it hmm what would
happen if I brought the coefficient out
the front and then reduce the quad well
it just happening okay let's just think
that visually Eddie give me a suggestion
arm well actually before you two go on
talking there's a lot of things to
observe tell you one thing don't pick
the whole picture form just pick one
thing up greatings always possible okay
fantastic number one whatever the green
function is it a better be all about the
axis because this is an increasing
function or its entire domain someone
great someone give you another piece of
information okay so number one we
already know it's going to stay positive
but it gets more and more positive as
time progresses right or i should say as
the x value increases because it's
getting steeper steeper yeah look at
this end is pretty flat isn't it all
right so we have always increasing so
therefore the gradient is positive we
have that it's getting steeper and
steeper and steeper can you tell me
anything else okay it never ever hear
zero which is kind of just to make sure
it's that we mean it's always positive
we don't just mean it's not negative we
mean it's actually always positive it's
look park here even though it gets quite
flat there's no part where it's actually
flat we're actually stops increasing
okay do we know anything else
see okay now interesting way the thing
you just described to me great
advantages always positive never zero
and its getting bigger and bigger and
bigger I asked you to describe the
gradient function it looks to me like
you just described this function all
those three properties that you just
mentioned right towards positive
navigates the axis of the Assam terms of
that and is increasing in value all the
way in other words it seems like we're
to Tony that the derivative of an
exponential looks a heck of a lot like
an excellent ok so you prove it to you
right you can put this if you like no
that's not much it is to listen there we
go you can put this into decimals if you
like right now look there's some of you
need in the invitation but anyway um
what I've done is I've plotted and
because I'm interested in like a few
different graphs not just one ok i
floated a to the X where a is a variable
I can make it up with it ok as you can
see it's there it's my green line let me
change that that's a bit easy to see ok
is that green line there it's all ceased
oh yeah wait why tax reason for
rejecting me now yeah um that green line
is pretty visible ok now this doesn't
look very exponentially to me why is
that it's my particular value for a of
the moment is what's 114 power anything
is one so there's a flag okay but as
soon as we change the tener encourage
you to actually actually put this into
desmos yourself so you can pluck about
with it and not just watch mini
microphone with it as soon as I change
value today things start to happen ok we
see
now let's just get to do you remember me
a doing student and that can get
everywhere ok here is you know what this
is not too bad ok so there's that should
be X and you can see if I muck around
with a we're going from a lower value
which is right straight across and the
course you get to one the more flattens
out versus a higher Bob the more you
gets sleep up okay so you get the idea
back then we go back okay now one of the
Handy things I don't know if you've
already worked out that there's what's
gonna do this for you it's um we can
calculate and therefore graph
derivatives on this like it'll just take
the water matically I think you've gotta
dig into I don't know actually is it
more tricky just type deal yet you just
do that if you can't the place i was
because i was lazy was when you enter
something if you get a functions you go
to a tease and if you go to the atheism
there's a few different ways to it
probably the most direct way is if you
go into functions miscellaneous d mdx
differentiate the operators just right
there and you too can put in the
derivative of whatever your function is
whatever you want okay can you can you
Brendan can you just let it just use
that so you can use am either backslash
to do that deficiency okay now watch as
I get rid of his keyboard business and
plot that derivative okay so sure enough
treaty instincts in fact i'll show you a
bit more of it
sure enough right you can see that
orange light there the derivative to the
X looks exactly like the exponential
function was done however you can see
it's kind of underneath all the way okay
i guess if we did our first principles
and we checked it at all these amazing
we could find out how much lower it is
but there you go okay now here's the
really fun part look about with that a
to the X again but i want you to notice
what's happening through the orange
graph you already know what's good what
the green graph is going to do it's
going to month becomes steeper or
shallow up i want you to watch the
orange raft okay watch carefully
okay I'm gonna stop there okay use words
what happened to the orange graph I
would you articulate it got its gone
lower hasn't it right and it's also gone
shallower now I start short of going all
the way because I hope you can see
there's a little bit limiting behavior
right you'd actually know what's going
to happen when I drag this all the way
back to one where I started what will
happen yeah if this is a horizontal way
the derivative will just be 0 because
it's not increasing or decreasing but as
I heard the other direction now let's
see
so those values i showed you before the
gradient line the gradient function was
beneath the function kpop its primitive
but now I've got a bar but I haven't
gone very far up at 4.8 i just happen to
cap off my values at five you can go as
far as you like and you make the orange
function as steep as you like okay let's
draw a conclusion from this okay all of
the orange functions what they share in
common is that they're all derivatives
right that are all Exponential's just
like they're primitives so here's what
I'm going to write me Tupac is the
derivative of some exponential function
right is essentially the same
exponential function but it's kind of
scaled vertically do you notice that
scale vertically like this one is higher
at every point higher in every single
point and if I put it back down you can
see okay our derivative now is lower at
every point so there's that same scale
or coding happening so what I conclude
from this i'm making a visual idea here
is that the derivative of an exponential
function is another exponential function
and its scale vertically in some way
okay so I'm going to say where K is some
real number I don't know anything about
what that real number is yet but I know
it is a number like that's all that's
happening is no actual Wiggles that have
been introduced into the ground no
station for is no change in behavior
essentially this is what's going on
probably 15 now we saw for some of the
graphs the derivative the orange line is
below and for others it's above that
makes me that petition sort of raised
their eyebrows and say well sometimes
it's below sometimes it's above they
must be a point where it's
April now I've only done it to be up in
your stint here so that's why I forget
the actual know that I'm I've done but
there's pre bang on right there is a
particular value where when you'd
appreciate you just get back something
pretty close you get back the actual
graph itself that you started with ok
that's a particular level some value of
a we give that number the name because
it's all about Exponential's we call it
e so we define we define e to be that
number such that if you spin this
experiment out and you try and find that
exact point where they line up perfectly
which you guys have met and I'm ready
for its 2.7 182 great one mate to right
and so on ok um it's a bit more rigorous
to prove that that number is what is but
you can see it already like you know I'm
in the right ballpark and that's what I
found sure ok so just to review this is
what I argued visually I'm lucky about
the scene what's happening this I've
defined right is the number such that
this happened because I don't have in
somewhere so that's my definition